wednesday pft p.m special guest today
texas defensive end jj watt that's
coming up momentarily before that though
the biggest news of the day and it's
been a very newsy week this one kind of
came out of the blue brett tesla who
represents 49ers running back for he
most who had that game for the ages in
the nfc championship against the packers
moster had been trying to get a new
contract from the 49ers he's due to make
2.75 million this year hasn't gotten
what he wanted and now he wants to be
traded this isn't necessarily the best
climate for any player to be trying to
finagle a trade with all the uncertainty
arising from the pandemic you'll hear a
lot about that from jj watt coming up in
a few minutes but the 49ers just have
this
revolving door that they've worked to
perfection and whoever they plug in
seems to get it done they still have
jared mckinnon who's been with the team
for two years trying to get to 100 they
believe that he still can be a very
effective player in that offense if he's
healthy they traded matt breida they've
got plenty of guys
i don't think they're gonna let
themselves be held hostage at the
running back position by one guy who
wants to be paid a lot of money because
they recognize maybe unlike any other
team
the value of having multiple running
backs who know the system it's about the
blocking it's about the play design and
there are a lot of guys out there we
talk about this all the time with
running backs the supply of capable
running backs far outweighs the demand
and that's very instructive as it
relates to the situation
with dalvin cook
in minnesota
same offensive philosophy
same approach and they've got alexander
madison who could step in if cook
decides to hold out
mostert wants out in san francisco if
they do trade him or if he holds out
they'll be fine
with the other guys that they have and
that's just kind of the way it is and
most or may not like it
but
the 49ers unlike any other team
understand that running backs i don't
want to quite say they're fungible
but they're pretty close to it
as anyone
with any position on offense or defense
would be in an nfl system
i think the 49ers feel that way about
the runnings back because we've seen
them get it done with a bunch of
different guys all right we got it done
with jj watt earlier today here's an
interview that i taped with him courtesy
of our friends at gatorade the beat the
heat program here's a conversation with
texas defensive nj walk
joining me now three-time nfl defensive
player of the year and one of the
cornerstone players of the houston
texans for the last decade he is the
great jj wadd and it is amazing to me
it's got to be amazing to you jj you're
number 10 coming up for you how fast has
that gone by
it's pretty crazy man uh it's it's gone
by fast for sure you know at the
beginning of your career they always
tell you uh it flies by it goes by in
the blink of an eye all the vets tell
you all that and you say yeah yeah yeah
but then you get here and you're 10 and
you're like
everything they said is true it goes by
extremely fast i have two brothers in
the nfl now it's wow
there's some similarities too between
year one and year ten year one there was
no off season program because of the
lockout this year no off season program
because of the pandemic is there
anything from nine years ago that you
can use to help make this easier when
you go to training camp without the
benefit of the off season program
yeah so when you think about the two off
seasons obviously neither one had otas
neither one had workouts with the team
um the biggest difference by far is
obviously the coronavirus situation and
what that causes is back in 2011 we
could still train at gyms we could still
get together and the veterans could
teach me the playbook we could run plays
we could do all that stuff we haven't
really been able to do that this off
season because of everything that's
going on so
i'm fortunate i had a situation where i
have a gym i have a field i can do all
my workouts there are some guys who live
in a one bedroom apartment who the
apartment building shut down the gym
they don't have a field to run on so
there's guys that are in different
situations all throughout the league so
where in 2011 if you weren't training it
was kind of your own fault because you
had access to everything this year it
might be you're not training because you
just didn't have access to it so i think
that's what we're having to deal with
and trying to figure out this ramp up
period and what it's going to take you
guys ready for the regular season is we
got to first assess what everybody's
been able to do and where their bodies
at because it's much different for every
guy and jj that's a great point too
because in 2011 injuries were up 25
even with the ability to work out in
gyms and work out in groups and work out
on fields this year there's a greater
risk of even
higher injury rates if there isn't that
break-in period that gets guys to where
they would have been if they'd had the
opportunity to work out
right and i think that's the biggest
concern from the players standpoint
besides the obvious health concerns of
covet itself
but the injury rate in figuring out
where guys bodies have been have they
been running at full speed have they
been cutting have they been making those
high impact you know moves that you have
to make to play the game of football
which is where a lot of those injuries
come from i mean you look back to 2011
and some of those histories hamstring
pulls achilles tears those are injuries
that happen because you haven't been
able to do what you need to do at that
highest level and so this year with the
circumstances we're at we just want to
make sure guys
aren't put in a compromised situation
purely because we want to start on the
set date
and sports leagues have been trying to
get back onto the field to court the
gridiron etc your wife's league the nwsl
chicago red stars they've been playing
what have you gleaned from her about
their experience playing games in the
pandemic that could maybe be useful when
it's time for you to get to work
yeah it's been a lot it's been
interesting for me to watch because uh
she went back to training you know a
month and a half two months ago whatever
it was and they uh she was in chicago
training and they were kind of self
quarantining themselves as they trained
to make sure that they could go to
practice every day and get their tests
and things like that and now around utah
in their own bubble um and so they're
basically all in one hotel they're
they're playing all their games at a
facility with no fans and the facilities
clean and everything's clean so it's
been really interesting for me to watch
and it's been successful for them so far
they really haven't had any you know
knock on wood they haven't had any
outbreaks or any cases there
and i think they've all been following
it pretty well uh not necessarily to the
most enjoyable
set of circumstances for him and she's
in a hotel room for you know 18 hours
out of the day when she's not training
but
it is working and so i think it's it's
kind of a give and take on you're going
to have to give up some you know
liberties and things that you're used to
and accustomed to you're not going to be
able to go out freely if you want to
have a season
like they're having where they're in a
bubble
but their trade-off is you get to play
the bubble concept's been tossed around
from time to time for the nfl i just
don't think it can work there's too many
teams too many players too many coaches
too many people but
the positive side if there is one would
be you know where everybody is i think
one of the practical realities jj for
the nfl yeah a lot of young guys they're
going to want to act like young guys and
they're going to be tempted to go out
and do the things young guys do and all
it takes is one of them bring that virus
into the facility or onto a field and
the nfl has a problem do you have any
any plans any strategies any ideas for
making sure at least your teammates will
do what they're supposed to do just go
home after practice stay there until
it's time to come back at the facility
you know i think that's kind of one
thing that we're all looking at the nba
and the mlb to see how it goes for them
i mean
we have an opportunity to where we don't
start for a little while after they do
so we've got an opportunity to learn and
i think obviously we should be taking
that opportunity to look and see what
works for them what doesn't work for
them do guys follow along with every set
of the protocols do the teams follow
along with every side of the protocol
it's going to be very interesting to see
and for us obviously being in our own
cities there is no matter how you slice
it no matter how hard you try to make it
as safe as possible there is going to be
some level of trust factor that's going
to have to come into play where you have
to trust that guys are going to be doing
the right thing on their free time
and that's i don't think that there's
i think it's very unrealistic to think
that it's 100
safe i don't think that's a that's a
realistic thing to think it has to come
down to how safe can you possibly get it
and are you comfortable taking that risk
and that's where you have to have that
option where if you're not comfortable
or if you're in a compromised situation
you have to be able to have that option
to not not be there
do you think a lot of guys are going to
do that a lot of guys like do you have a
rough idea of a percentage that would
surprise you uh if if guys
say yeah i just can't do it this year
i'm i'm not i'm not going to be part of
this
i don't i really don't i think that
every guy's situation is different you
know i know some like there could be a
guy who has a child with asthma and he
really just doesn't want to bring it
back home or you have a pregnant wife
and i think that the one thing that i
would say
to that is there shouldn't be a stigma
if you do choose to about if there if
there is a legitimate reason for you to
be opting out you don't feel comfortable
whether it's for yourself whether it's
for your family i don't personally think
there should be a stigma with that
because that's you're making the best
decision for yourself and for your
family and
if we ever get to the point where we're
shaming people for dropping out of a
sport
because they want to protect the health
of their family then we're in a tough
spot
yeah i agree with you on that and i have
a copy of the protocol that's been put
in place between the leading the union
for training camp and everything looks
appropriate six feet apart mass
everything's careful everything is very
deliberate and planned out
but the more i see that the harder it is
to reconcile at some point everybody's
got to get on a football field you're
gonna be lined up right across from
somebody as rodney harrison told me last
week breathing and sweating and spitting
and and bleeding and
how how do you reconcile the two
that's what we are trying to do you know
so as players
i've been on these pa calls last you
know we've got calls every three days
now as we get closer trying to figure
all this out and the biggest thing that
we want is just answers to these
questions that we have just like you
have a question there you know how we
want we want answers to the same
questions there's more questions not
just that there's other questions and so
the last thing that we want as players
is for this report date to be set in
stone
and for us to be bumping up against this
report date and then we hastily put
things together just because we want to
make sure that that report date is met i
think the most important thing for us is
getting everything right so that
everybody feels as safe as possible as
comfortable as possible with what we're
gonna do whether that is on the report
date whether that's push back whatever
it may be but i just don't want us to
get into a situation where we bump up to
this report date and we say oh no now we
got to figure it out that's where you
get yourself in the truck i want to let
you keep on your schedule jj you're here
on behalf of the gatorade beat the heat
program tell us more about that
yeah so like you said at the beginning
of this interview 10 years i've been in
this league and we actually started the
gatorade beat the heat program 10 years
ago when i when i came down here from
wisconsin down to houston it was a
climate shock for me i mean it's 110
degrees there's humidity like crazy down
here so i had to learn how to beat the
heat myself
and one of the biggest things i learned
was that if you weigh yourself before a
workout and you weigh yourself after a
workout up in the heat every every one
pound of body weight that you lose you
have to drink 20 ounces of gatorade to
replenish yourself um so during training
camp i mean you could lose six seven
eight pounds depending on the heat
depending on you know pads and
everything
so it's extremely important to get that
electrolytes back in your body and
replenish yourself so you're ready for
the next day and this year more than
ever it's going to be important because
of how hot it is we're training on our
own and now there's going to be many
protocols in place so gatorade has been
good to me and they've always helped me
beat the heat so i'm just trying to pass
on the message
i saw a tweet you had about a month ago
about the possibility of the face shield
inside the face mask all the way down
that does not beat the heat does it i i
might i
my uh second year in the league you know
i i thought it'd be cool i put a visor
on my head i was like it looks so cool i
want to put a visor on i had it on for
about three periods of practice and i
said take this sucker off i'm gonna die
out here i just i literally just the
face one so now you're gonna put
something around my mouth and you can
keep that if that if that comes into
play i don't think you're going to see
me out there in the field
well hey jj we wish you all the best we
hope football gets it all figured out
hope to see you on the field this season
look forward to talking to you again
soon thanks i appreciate it have a good
one bye take care pop
thanks again to gatorade and jj watt for
giving us some time today and look
it really is becoming more and more
clear as we get closer to july 28th that
there is no certainty there is no sure
thing there is no
way to reconcile social distancing with
playing football
and
the problem is
and look there's there's nothing
political about this it shouldn't be
regarded as political it's reality
in the united states of america we have
failed to take the pandemic as seriously
as other countries have
period full stop
premier league playing games bundesliga
playing games why
because the virus isn't running rampant
in those countries see this isn't about
whether or not what extent things will
be safe in a facility or on a practice
field or a game site this is about
whether or not you can keep your guys
from getting infected elsewhere
and then bringing it to work and
catching it before they infect
someone else
that's now the risk and we didn't think
that was going to be the situation by
the time august and september rolled
around that's what we need to be
concerned about so nfl and nflpa trying
to work it out jj watt hit the nail on
the head there should be no stigma
whatsoever if guys decide to opt out
it's unclear who will or who won't
the problem is football players want to
play football and i think there will be
guys who maybe should opt out
and don't
and that's all right too each guy's got
to make his own decision about what's
right for him and the reality is for
every guy that opts out there's 5 10 15
20 guys out there that will say i'll do
it and the nfl will find a way to put
enough players on the field the
challenge will be
avoiding the kind of outbreaks that will
shut a team down
and having enough
able
ready and willing players who can step
in
and go
and you don't want to have your 40
million a year quarterback being
protected by a left guard who was just
scraped off of a couch because they're
15 guys deep on who they're trying to
get to come play because everybody else
has the virus all right we hope they get
it worked out though we hope we have
football and when we have football
it looks like washington's gonna have a
new name and it looks like there will be
no native american imagery now i don't
know what that means
does that mean that there will be a
potential native american name
but not
any native american
imagery i don't know but i think at a
minimum it means in addition to the word
being taken off of the bottom of the
neck of the jerseys you're going to have
the logos scraped off of the side of the
helmet and something new is going to be
placed on there and look
the washington post had a story
yesterday explaining how difficult it is
to change the name of a franchise to
re-brand a franchise quickly it takes
time trademark applications have to be
fought things have to be done you don't
just flip a switch and change the name
but here's the problem
the problem is this name should have
been changed a long time ago
and
whatever hassles the franchise is going
to have to deal with in changing this
name on an expedited basis that's part
of the debt that you accrue by refusing
to do the right thing and change the
name when you should have years ago when
dan schneider crossed his arms like
verruckt assault and said never and you
can put it in all caps that's when the
clock started ticking that's when anyone
paying attention to this new you know
what at some point they're gonna have to
change that name now nobody could have
foreseen this specific circumstance this
awakening and reckoning on racial issues
that has caused everyone
to be more sensitive than ever before
more thoughtful than ever before more
vocal than ever before but regardless
when you decide to go forward with a
dictionary defined slurs the name of the
team you run the risk that the walls are
going to collapse quickly and you're
going to have to move faster than you
ever would under normal circumstances
and to the extent that that's what
washington has to do that's what
washington has to do and meanwhile to
the extent that anyone wants to make a
run on all of the soon-to-be obsolete
washington gear you're not going to get
it at target you're not going to get it
at nike you're not going to get it at
walmart you're not going to get it
via amazon all of those retailers
no washington merchandise to be found
nfl shop fanatics the only place you can
get of course ebay and i guess there's
going to be a pretty robust market on
ebay and etsy and other
other
sellers out there of second-hand goods
because there will be people i guarantee
it as sad as it is there will be people
who continue to call the team by its
current name continue to wear the gear
associated with the current name but
it's a little bit harder to find that
gear now than it was a week ago and
hopefully a week two weeks three weeks
four weeks from now
at some point before they go to training
camp i mean isn't it going to be awkward
when it's so clear that they're going to
change the name that they continue to go
by the name that is going to be changed
the name that is going to be changed
because
it's offensive to native americans but
what do we call well just column
washington like i've been doing for the
last seven years so
washington hopefully will have a new
name until then i hope everyone just
refers to them as
washington you can refer to us as pft pm
the break from pft live continues we're
back july 20th pft p.m rolling along
every weekday we'll be back again
tomorrow with another edition of pftpm
until then check us out around the clock
at profootballtalk.com and have a great
day
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports